so we have a bit of a light-hearted
story to wrap things up today and it has
to do with one of the worst pandemic
inspired changes to our society which is
of course the dreaded qr code at
restaurants replacing physical menus we
know that during the pandemic businesses
would try to take advantage of the
situation by not providing us with
things that we were used to and just
using kobat as an excuse like they would
say oh sorry we can't clean your hotel
room because of kovid and sorry you
can't bring your reusable bag to the
grocery store because of cobit remember
that one well none of these changes were
as bad as the dreaded qr code scanner at
restaurants and while some of the
pandemic era inconveniences are no more
the dreaded qr code at restaurants
persist and the idea of introducing them
in the first place was pretty clear you
don't have people touching the menus
that way you don't have to sanitize the
menus as often and it's the same reason
why restaurants during the height of the
pandemic got rid of the ketchup bottles
on the tables and the salt and pepper
shakers and it didn't take long for us
to learn that the virus was largely an
airborne transmitted virus it didn't
really transfer that much from surfaces
so a lot of these changes that we made
were pointless and we could have
backtracked on them right then and there
pretty early on in the pandemic but
restaurants persisted with the qr thing
because printing menus can be expensive
you need to replace them sometimes when
they get dirty or when you change the
menu you got to think about the printing
costs and it's also in a low labor
environment just better for businesses
to have the qr codes because you don't
have to have staff distribute and
collect the menus but customers
absolutely revile the qr code myself
included a recent technomic survey found
that about 88 of respondents said that
they preferred paper menus to digital qr
codes about 66 percent of respondents
agreed or strongly agreed that they
didn't like qr codes because they
involve pulling out your phone as soon
as you sit down at the table about 57
agreed that using qr codes felt like a
chore and 55 agreed that qr codes were
hard to read and browse through and it
actually does seem to make sense for
restaurants to bring back the physical
menus now not just because customers
hate it and they'll sometimes leave
these awful reviews for restaurants
because of the qr codes the qr codes
actually are leading to people ordering
less because if you have a menu left on
the table for example sometimes it'll
have the pictures of the food and the
drinks and the desserts and everything
so you may be tempted to order more just
by giving a glance over at it and saying
oh that looks good i want to order that
whereas if you have to pull out your
phone scan the qr code open up the
website scroll down find what you're
looking for that's more of an active
action versus a passive action of just
glancing at something and saying that
looks good i want that now depending on
my mood i will sometimes lie at the
restaurant and i'll say i don't have a
phone or i have a flip phone and so i
need a physical menu that is something
that you can try out at home there
they'll have a few physical menus at
their ready so they're probably not
going to be happy to give it to you but
you can always just make up an excuse
and i'm sure you'll get it and another
pro tip for dealing with the other
inconvenience that people absolutely
hate at restaurants is when you're about
to pay for the meal just have cash handy
with the tip included so that when the
server comes over you can just pay for
it all at once they bring you the check
you look at the amount you probably know
about what it's going to be you just
give them the cash they go on with it
rather than having to give them a card
they leave come back and then you fill
out the tip and everything it saves you
about half the headache because that's
one of the things that people hate most
about restaurants having to wait at the
end of your meal when you just want to
get up and leave all right that's going
to do it for today's show my thank you
to david for allowing me to fill in for
him today while he is traveling up in
montreal and we're going to have farron
cousins fill in the next couple of days
david will be back on thursday and
friday to finish out the week and if you
want more of the david pakman show be
sure to check out today's bonus show
which you can access by signing up for a
membership at joinpacman.com
or contributing to patreon at the five
dollar level at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i'll see you on the bona
show